welcome everybody uh we're gonna sort of
close out the cancun cruise
fiasco a little bit later in the show
but to talk about
sort of good things that came out of
this horrible situation in texas
we have a remarkable situation in the
united states
where a democratic new york
congresswoman
seems to be better representing the
interests
of texas residents than their own
actual republican u.s senator ted cruz
i'm talking about
democratic congresswoman alexandria
ocasio-cortez
as well as texas democrat beto o'rourke
and other democrats who came together
and while
ted cruz was flying back and forth to
cancun mexico
appearing on the sean hannity program to
give conflict conflicting and bizarre
explanations
about uh exactly why he thought it was a
good idea at any point to go to cancun
in the midst of storms and power outages
afflicting his state
in the midst of all that alexandria
ocasio-cortez
uh took to twitter to announce a
fundraising effort
within two hours she raised three
hundred and twenty five thousand dollars
by yesterday morning she and beto
o'rourke and others
had raised more than four million
dollars and there's a good chance that
by the time you listen to today's show
and watch this clip
she will have raised five million or
more dollars
for texas victims of these storms and
power outages
she also didn't just do online
fundraising
she actually went down to fill up food
boxes
at a houston food bank with uh
representatives sylvia garcia
and al green and sheila jackson lee and
in the midst of all of this insanity
with texas politicians who voted against
hurricane sandy aid but that said give
us the texas aid now
for the power outages and flew to cancun
and back and said oh
the girls wanted to go on
it is alexandria ocasio-cortez
supposedly enemy number one for a lot of
these republicans
who has actually put boots on the ground
for lack of a better term
raised money got food boxes together for
people unable to get food
and again when you are a texas voter
and you see that a democratic
congresswoman from another state
is doing more for you than your own
senator um it really should make you
reconsider whether you were represented
by the best people and
i sent out a couple of tweets about this
i tweeted over the weekend have ted cruz
greg abbott
and others thanked aoc for her huge
fundraising for texas victims of the
storms and power outages
as of this moment they have not but i
wouldn't be surprised
if at some point they sort of feel
obligated to put together some kind of
perfunctory
thank you to all of those who have
helped us in our relief efforts
also i tweeted this morning the texas
fundraising story is crazy
it genuinely seems like aoc and beto
o'rourke
haven't embezzled any of the money nor
put their families on staff to funnel
cash to them
something that became basically standard
operating procedure
under the trump administration donald
trump putting
everybody from lara trump to who knows
who else on his campaign staff paying
them 180 grand a year
and so on and so forth now what just one
other side story with the insanity of
this
not only have aoc and better or work
done more
for texas than has ted cruz ted cruz
ended up desperately attempting a pr
uh photo op where he was putting uh
packages of bottled water
in the trunks and vehicles of texans and
it's like
there's no more pathetic attempt to make
up for his flying to cancun than
to be photographed handing out water but
that raised another question
why isn't ted cruz in quarantine right
now ted cruz
flew to mexico and then flew back the
next day
was he tested in mexico in the 20 hours
or 18 hours that he was there
do we know for sure that ted cruz is not
potentially
positive for coronavirus right now
shouldn't he be
and absent a coronavirus test
quarantining right now rather than out
and about like
we may never know the answers to these
questions uh
and of course we were all asking wait a
second
he went he had kid ted cruz admits that
he had a bunch of his
daughter's friends over for dinner the
day before going to cancun
and then he went to cancun and then he
flew back the next day
is he being tested at any point during
this is he adhering to the protocols
about requiring tests to go to mexico to
come back to mexico by the united states
we just have no idea and we may never
even get answers to these questions but
they're questions we're not ignoring
is it some kind of exception for
senators i don't know
but we should be getting answers to this
and of course with ted cruz as with many
of these people
it's yeah sure these are the rules but
not for me
and uh that seems to apply unfortunately
to many of our leaders and it's not just
republicans that that's the case
with but we will talk a little bit more
about the ted cruz fiasco
later on when you see me sitting here at
the microphone oftentimes i'm wearing a
shirt by a company called
teddy stratford and i love these shirts
so much that i asked teddy stratford to
be a sponsor of the show
and here's why i like their shirt so
much with other slim fit button-up
shirts
you often get this weird looking gap
between the buttons where it looks kind
of stretched out but teddy stratford
actually has a patented zipper that's
hidden
underneath the buttons which secures the
shirt against your chest so it doesn't
look
stretched and most importantly it just
provides a nicer looking fit overall
and the entire shirt is specially
designed to really improve the way your
upper body looks when you're wearing it
it also has a special type of collar
that prevents it from drooping down
and spreading open which is another
really great thing about these shirts
all of these things really do a lot to
make a big difference when you're
looking at a shirt
and that's why i like to wear teddy
stratford shirts on the show
go check them out at davidpakman.com
teddy the link is down below and they'll
give you 15
off your first order if you use the
coupon code pacman at checkout